the two percent jump from last week
alone follows an upward trend that
started in october
if things don't get better in the next
nine days governor siselek says we could
see
new restrictions again 8 news now
reporter madison kimbrough joins us live
tonight with more details on this
madison yes sasha with almost 13
thousand
cases and tests being performed this
weekend kofi 19 cases are surging and if
we don't see a decline soon
we could be headed towards a major
shutdown
test positivity has grown to 15.1
percent
in just the last couple of days that's
according to the nevada department of
health and human services
data from saturday shows an upward trend
that has been climbing
since halloween there's now a total of
120 thousand
183 confirmed co-fit 19 cases statewide
with over 95 thousand in clark county
alone
more than a third of the cases reported
in clark county are among hispanics
making it the most impacted ethnic group
locally and it's predominantly those in
the 25 to 49 year old age range
that make up the majority of those
infected in our county
washoe county is reporting a record 561
additional coveted 19 cases
and that is a single day record the
numbers reaching to 65 percent over the
past week
as alarming as it may be the record for
most cases in one day in the reno area
has been set three different times in
the last nine days
reno mayor hillary chevy also warned
residents that stricter enforcement
could be on the horizon
saying she will ask the city council to
authorize fines for
failure to wear face coverings for a
two-month period if need be
and we are currently nine days away from
the end of the stay-at-home 2.0
mandate so because of the influx of
cases there are new testing sites being
open
every single day of course we'll have a
full list up on our website
reporting live madison kimbrough 8 news
now